[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياب في العناوين
بدوي انشائي سياج عازل في درنا الليبيه
حول المنطقه الاكثر تضررا من السيول
السلطات تؤكد ان الهدف هو تسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ والحمايه من او بيئه محتمله
والجزيره ترصد احوال الناجين من الفيضانات
تسارع عمليته ايواء المنكوبين من زلزال
الحوز في المغرب والديوان الملكي يعلن
تخصيص اثني عشر مليار دولار للمرحله
الاولى من اعاده اعمار المناطق المتضرره
بعد مواجهات عسكريه استمرت يوما واحدا
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار في اقليم كاراباخ
عليه يقول ان اذربيجان استعادت سيادتها
وباشنيان يدعو المجتمع الدولي لتوفير
ضمانات امنيه بسكان الاقليم
[موسيقى]
نبدا بالمشهد في الشرق الليبي فقد اعلنت
السلطات تقسيم مدينه الدرنه حسب الاضرار
التي لحقت باحيائها واخلاء الاحياء الاكثر
تضررا من سكانها وذلك لتسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ وحمايه النجيم فيما اعلنت وكاله
الانباء الليبيه البدء في اقامه سياج عازل
حول المنطقه المنكوبه في المدينه وفي غضون
ذلك تتواصل جهود البحث عن المفقودين
ومحاولات انتشار جثث الضحايا فيما تستمر
اعمال تنظيف وتعقيم شوارع المدينه من
جانبها اعلنت لجنه الاستجابه للطوارئ
مشاركه 14 فريق انقاذ بينها 10 من الخارج
كما بدات الفرق الطبيه حمله تطعيمات
للاطباء والناجين في محاوله لمنع انتشار
الامراض في المدينه المنكوبه
هذا فقط اثارت صور اقمار صناعيه مزيدا من
الدمار الذي وقع في مناطق شرقيه ليبيا
نتيجه الاعصار دانيال حيث سويت قرن
باكملها في الاثناء قالت غرفه عمليه طوارئ
صحه المجتمع في ليبيا انها ستقسم مدينه
درنه الى ثلاث مناطق لتسهيل عمل فريق
الاسعاف وكذلك للانقاذ
[موسيقى]
الشرق الليبي بعد من هول الاعصار دانيال
ومات له من سيول جرفت مناطق واسعه بشكل
شبهي يومي يتم الكشف عن المزيد من الاضرار
التي خلفتها الكارثه تشير احدث المعطيات
ان قرن باكملها محيت من الخريطه في ليبيا
كقريه المخيلي الواقعه بين طبرق وبنغازي
كما تظهر صور اقمار صناعيه ما تحلى
بالقريه قبل وبعد الاعصار والفيضان ليتكشف
حجم الدمار الضرر يمتد بشكل اكثر وضوحا
ويتبدى في دارنه غرفه عمليات طوارئ صحه
المجتمع قالت انها تعمل على تحديد ثلاث
مناطق جغرافيه في المدينه بحسب حجم التاثر
المنطقه الاولى وهي المنطقه المتضرره التي
لا يمكن العيش فيها وبالتالي تبرز الحاجه
لاجلاء السكان منها عدا فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف وتتشكل من وسط مدينه درنه
المنطقه الثانيه وهي المنطقه الهشه التي
غمرتها المياه ويشكل العيش فيها خطوره على
السكان تقع هذه المنطقه في بعض شوارع محله
الجبيله والمغار المنطقه الثالثه وهي
القابله للعيش في حي باب شيحه الغربي وشيح
الشرقي وباب الطبرق والساحل الشرقي
وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره الداخليه في
الحكومه المكلفه من قبل مجلس النواب طارق
الخراز ان هناك خطه لعزل المناطق الاكثر
تضررا في دارنا اما وزير الصحه في الحكومه
المكلفه من مجلس النواب عثمان عبد الجليل
فتحدث عن عزل منطقه واحده داخل دارنا
وتشير البيانات المتاحه الى وجود اكثر من
4000 وثلاثمائه وخمسه وخمسين مبنى قبل
الفيضان في درنه لتنخفض بعد العاصفه
العاتيه الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه وثمانيه
وعشرين مبنى
وبعد اسبوع على فيضان مدينه درنه ما زالت
المدينه تحصي ضحاياها من قتلى ومفقودين
وبينما تتواصل عمليه الانقاذ تتراجع
الامال في ايجاد ناجين حيث تقوم فرق البحث
باستخراج الجثث ويثير هذا الامر مخاوفه
صحيه في ظل الاعلان عن اصابات في صفوف
الجيش وفرق الانقاذ باعراض الاسهال والقيء
وغيرهما
من علي يتبين هول الماساه فهذا ما تبقى من
مدينه درنه
غير سيل ملامحها تماما
بعد اكثر من اسبوع على الكارثه يواصل
الناجون احصاء خساراتهم وهي فادحه فادحه
جدا
الوجع الممتد في المدينه يكتب على الجدران
غير بعيد من الركام تحولت هذه الخيمه الى
مقر هزاع
لكن من يعزي من فما من احد منهم لم يترك
الموت باب بيته جميعهم مكلومون
لا
اله الا الله طارق فقد زوجته وابنائه
الثلاثه وعشرين اخرين من اقاربه
سيدنا مصيبه مصيبه يا راجل بنتي الكبيره
ثانيه العلم الحيوان
وفقدت ولدي كليه هندسه يكمل شهر اربعه
القادم
يعني سنه اعدادي هذا معد قدامي
تتشابه التفاصيل وتتكرر قصص الموت المفجعه
في هذه المدينه المنكوبه
بحثا عن المفقودين تواصل فرق الانقاذ
المحليه والدوليه ازاله الركام لكن دون
امل تقريبا في الوصول الى ناجين
وحدها الجثه هي التي تخرج من بين الركام
[موسيقى]
فرصه وجود ناجين ضعيفه لكن الامل في الله
ان شاء الله
ولازلنا في طور البحث عن الجثث وعن
المفقودين
العمل كبير والله
هكذا تحولت البيوت الى مقابر لسكانها
وليست وحدها في ذلك
بحر المدينه غدا وجه ماساتها الاخر اليه
حمل السيل كل ما صادفه في طريقه
يقوم هؤلاء الغواصون القادمون من تونس
بعمل مظلم لاستخراج الجثث لكن المهمه
معقده معظم الجثث عالق تحت الصخور وداخل
السيارات
جثث اخرى ما زالت في هذا البحر وقد لا يتم
اخراجها ابدا بسبب عظم الكارثه وقله
الامكانات
لكن يخشى ان تجرا الكوارث بعضها بعضها
فثمت مخاوفه من حدوث مضاعفات وبائيه بسبب
مخلفات الفيضان
هكذا بدا ان عجله الحياه قد توقفت اوكادت
في درنه رغم كل شيء لا تخلو المدينه من
رسائل الامل التي تبشر بالنجاه ومن بين
الركام يتطلع ابنائها الى تعافي مدينتهم
وقلوبهم
محمد البقالي الجزيره
درنا شرقي ليبيا
وفي غضور ذلك تتواصل ببناء درنا عمليات
استخراج الجثث من عرض البحر مراسلنا تامر
الصمادي يطلعنا على اخر مشاهداته من هناك
قبل بدء قرار السلطات الصحيه وقفه عمل
الصحافيين في المناطق المنكوبه جراء
الفيضانات التي اجتاحت المدينه مؤخرا
هذه واحده من جثث كثيره تم انتشالها خلال
الساعات الماضيه من البحر هذا البحر الذي
التهم الكثير من سكان المدينه المتضرره
بفعل الفيضانات اعمال الانقاذ تتواصل بشكل
مستمر لا سيما في المناطق التي يعني ضربها
الاعصار بقوه تلك المركبات كما تشاهدون هي
لشرق متخصصه تعمل على طول الشواطئ
المنتشره على بحر درنه وعمليات عزل
المدينه بدات تتواصل وتستمر الحديث عن هذا
السياج مثلا الذي سوف
يحيط بكل المناطق المدمره والمنكوبه لا
سيما عند منطقه الوادي وادي دارنا
بالاضافه الى حي الصحابه الذي بات اثرا
بعد عين والذي تواصل فيه الفرق الصحيه
القيام باعمال متواصله للوصول الى الجثث
السلطات قسمت المدينه خلال الساعات
الماضيه ثلاثه اقسام نتحدث عن القسم الف
وهو الاكثر دمارا والذي ستبدا فيه السلطات
باخلاء من تبقى من سكان على قيد الحياه
ليتسنى للفرق الصحيه القيام باعمالها
وانتشال ما يمكن من جثث الوضع كارثي
للغايه مع مرور الوقت الوضع صعب جدا
ودائره الامل تضيق لاسيما فيما يخص العثور
على احياء وفقا للسلطات الصحيه في المدينه
تابرسنال الجزيره درنح
معنى منا طرابلس المحي الدين لويجي الناطق
باسم وزاره الصحه بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
اهلا بك سيد محي الدين لنبدا بهذه الرسائل
ربما المتناقضه بين الطمانه بعدم وجود او
في هذه المناطق المنكوبه وبين التحذير من
مؤشرات ومخاطر حدوث اوبئه في هذه الاماكن
ما طبيعه الوضع سيد محي الدين
بدايه اهلا وسهلا بك مرحبا ونرحب بكافه
جهودكم مبدوله في نقل صوتكم
بالنسبه
للتخوف من الامراض صحيح وزاره الصحه ابدى
التخوفها من انتقال الامراض التي تنتقل عن
طريق الحشرات
المتواجده في المياه الراكده عن طريق
التسممات البيئيه
نؤكد انه لا يوجد الى الان اي وباء منتشر
في المنطقه ما وجد في مدينه درنه فقط تسمم
تسمم عن طريق تلوث المياه الوضع الوبائي
جيد جدا
الفرق الخاصه بالرصد والتقصي تعمل بجهد في
هذه المناطق ولله الحمد الى حد الان لا
يوجد اي وباء منتشر في هذه المناطق طيب
ماذا تقول اخر تقاريركم عن المتابعات
الصحيه في هذه الاماكن المنكوبه سيد محي
الدين
والله التقرير الاخير من المركز الوطني
مكافحه الامراض يقول انه عشر حاله تسمم من
مياه الشرب فقط تمت السيطره على اغلب
حالات تسمم حيث وصلت الايام الماضيه الى
150 حاله الان لدينا 12 حاله فقط
اجمال التقارير الطبيه فيما يتعلق بانتشال
الجثث متابعه
المصابين التكفل صحيا توفير المياه
الصالحه للشرب الى غير ذلك ماذا تقول اخر
تقاريركم سيد محي الدين
تم توفير المياه اللازمه للشرب بعد
التحذيرات التي اطلقتها وزاره الصحه يوجد
العدد الكافي من المياه يوجد وعي لدى
المواطنين في هذه المناطق بعالم من عدم
استعمال المياه سواء في الغسيل او في
الشرب
يعتبر وضع التسمم تيم تمت السيطره عليه
ولله الحمد
طيب ماذا عن التكفل بالجرحى وتوفير
المستلزمات في الاماكن ومساله البحث
مواصله البحث عن الجثث واستخراجها من هذه
مع طبعا مع صعوبه هذه المهمه
بالنسبه للوضع الصحي الوضع الصحي يعتبر
جيد جدا وزاره الصحه قدمت كل ما لديها من
توفير في ادويه وفي مستلزمات طبيه تم
ارسال اكثر من 90 حاويه ممكن وصلنا الى 99
حاويه خاصه بالادويه والمستلزمات الى شرق
ليبيا في مخازن جهاز الامداد الطبي
بالمنطقه تم توفير التطعيمات اللازمه الان
فرق المركز الوطني مكافحه الامراض تقوم
بتحصينات لعدد كبير من الاطفال وتحصينات
للاطقم الطبيه المشاركه في عمليات انتشار
الجثث يوجد شغل كبير ولله الحمد في هذه
المناطق
جميع الفرق جاهزه اكثر من 165 عنصر حاليا
متواجدون في خدمه
المركز الوطني لمكافحه الامراض للتقصي
ان يكونوا جاهزين في اي وقت لاي مرض محتمل
شكرا لك سيد محي الدين نويجي كنت معنا من
طرابلس وانت ناطق باسم وزاره الصحه بحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
وينضم الينا من
[موسيقى]
وهو المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الدولي
جمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر سيد
لويسو ماذا تقول تقاريركم عن المتابعات
للوضع الصحي في المناطق المنكوبه في ليبيا
جزيلا لاستضافه الوضع هناك معقد حقيقه فقد
سمعنا من زملائنا من جمعيه الاحمر الليبي
والبقيه الوفود هناك فقط مستشفى واحد يعمل
هناك ونعلم ان ذلك غير كافي وبالتالي
فالدعم الصحي لقد يكون مهم جدا لقاء الناس
على القيد الحياه وهذا امر مصدر قلق شديد
لنا اضافه لنا مشكله المياه الصالحه للشرب
ومسائل الصحيه الاخرى
مثل هذه الكوارث الصعبه العمل على الصحه
والمياه
ومهم جدا لتجنب ايه تدهورات اخرى واضرار
صحيه ما الذي يستطيع المجتمع الدولي ان
يفعله في هذه الظروف
الاتحاد الدولي للجمعيات الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر تعمل بنشاط كبير
وان فعلا لدينا مكتب هناك كان لدينا حتى
قبل هذه الحاله الطارئه وبالتالي بدانا
بالعمل فورا مع الهلال الاحمر الليبي
وعرفنا ما هي احتياجاتهم واولوياتهم
وبعثناهم بعض الاموال الطارئه واطلقنا
المناشد عشره ملايين دولار طارئه لنطلب
منه شركائنا
المساعده للدعم هذه النشاطات وبالتالي نحن
فان هناك لتقديم الدعم للمستجبين لاوائل
من الهلال الاحمر الليبي وهنا
بعض هؤلاء كانوا في درنا حتى قبل الماساه
وسيصلون البقاء هناك ليعرفوا بالضبط ما
يحتياجات المنطقه والناس عن الاحتياجات هل
التكفل الطبي يقف فقط عند
من تاذوا طبعا اتكلم هنا جسديا في هذه
الماساه هناك جانب نفسي مهم يتعلق بهول
الصدمه من فقدوا ذويهم في هذا في هذه
الكارثه هل هناك مشروع هل هناك تصور لخطه
ما حيال هؤلاء
نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا على هذا السؤال فهذا
امر مهم جدا فالدعم الاجتماعي والذهني
اللي هو اولويه دائما بالنسبه لنا فبعد كل
كارثه وبعثت حاله الطارئه نعلم مع الاسف
عن طريق خبرتنا انه بعد حالات طارئه مثل
هذه الناس يوصلون الشعور بالخوف والقلق
لاشهر اسابيعا قادمه وبالتالي نعلم ان
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي لابد ان يبدا
فورا كارثه مباشره وان استهلال الاحمر
الذي بدا ذلك فعلا واننا ايضا ضمن
مناشيرتنا ان نقول بدعم مثل هذه الجهد في
هذا الاتجاه
لتحول الى حلول وصل على المدى المتوسطه
البعيد للناس الذين تعرضوا للفيضانات
الذين الان يعيشون في بني عامه ومدارس ذلك
ولكن هذا قد يكون حاله طارئه مؤقتا ولكن
لابد
القادمه كما اننا نقدم بتوفير الماوى
والصحه والماء والغذاء وايضا لابد نتحدث
عن عيشها ولا الناس فهؤلاء الناس ما كل
شيء خلال الساعات وبالتالي يحتاجون الدعمه
وتضامن المجتمع الدولي لاشهر وسنوات قادمه
لهذا السبب نحن هنا في نيويورك لدعوه
المجتمع الدولي ليواصل دعم الناس
المتاثرين هناك في ليبيا ثم صعد
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الدولي
لجماعه جمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر كنت معنا من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلنا المغرب اعتماد 120 مليار درهم بما
يساوي 12 مليار دولار لبرنامج اعاده ايواء
المتضررين من زلزال الحوز ويستهدف
البرنامج نحو اربعه ملايين و200 الف نسمه
على مدى خمس سنوات وخلال جلسه عمل مخصصه
لمتابعه تنفيذ عمليه اعاده اعمار المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال دعا العاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس الى تفعيل الرؤيه التي
اعدت لاعاده ايواء المتضررين وتشجيع
الانشطه الاقتصاديه بجميع الاقاليم
المتضرره من الزلزال وشدد العاهل المغربي
على اهميه التركيز على احتياجات المتضررين
من اجل تقديم الحلول الملائمه لهم مع
ايلاء الاهميه للبعد البيئي وانماط عيش كل
منطقه
وتبقى الامال معقوده على الوصول الى احياء
تحت الانقاذ رغم مرور كل هذه الايام اذ
تواصل فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه عمليه البحث
اثراء زلزال اقليم الحوز الذي وقع في
الثامن من الشهر الجاري وقالت وزاره الصحه
المغربيه ان عدد الجرح الذين تكفلت بهم
وزاره الصحه بلغ
16,076 شخصا بينهم 1205 اشخاص اصابتهم
خطيره ونحو
492 اصابتهم طفيفه كما اشارت الوزاره الى
ان عدد المصابين في المستشفيات يصل حاليا
الى
375 بينهم 54 في اقسام العنايه المركزه في
غضون ذلك بدات السلطات المغربيه عمليه
احصاء المباني المتضرره تمهيدا لاعاده
الاعمار
واكدت وزاره التجهيز والنقل المغربي ان
مصالحها الاقليميه بالحوز تمكنت من فتح
نحو 90% من الطرق القرويه المغلقه الرابطه
بين الطرق الرئيسيه والتجمعات السكنيه
النائيه واوضح المدير الاقليبي للوزاره
باقليم الحوز هشام فرندي للجزيره ان الفرق
الميدانيه التابعه للوزاره تركز حاليا على
فتح الطرق بالمناطق المنكوبه
كان اعداد واحد برنامج تدخل على مستوى
مركز القياده بالعماله ومن خلاله صخره
الوزاره الاليات والموارد البشريه
التي تؤدينا للدواوير لفك الحمد لله اليوم
تقريبا تم كنا من فتح واحد 90% او نسبه
90% ديالنا في
تنستمر العمل ديالنا
من مراكش مراسل الجزيره المختار العلوي
ونبدا معك بكل هذه الجهود المختار سواء
متعلق منها بهذا الخبر الهام وهو فتح هذه
الطرق حتى على هذه القرى والدواوير طبعا
الدواوير هي القرى الصغيره النائيه في
جبال الاطلس محاوله فتح الطرق والوصول لها
اضافه الى جهود الدوله في توفير هذا
الغلاف المالي للتكفل ما بعد هذا الزلزال
نعم عبد القادر الجهود تتواصل من اجل فتح
الطرقات والطرقات هي الموجوده هنا سواء في
اقليم تارودانت في هذا الاتجاه او ايضا في
بقيه البلدات
كامزميزات من البلدات المتضرره كان لافتا
ما صدر في بيانا البلاء في بلاغ الديوان
الملكي 120 مليار درهم اي اثنين عشره
مليار دولار على مدى خمس سنوات بعمليه
حسابيه بسيطه
مليارين و400 مليون دولار لكل سنه هذا
الرقم سيوزع على الاقاليم الخمسه او
الاقاليم السته التي تضررت وهي ازيلال
تارودانت ورزازات الحوز مراكش وازيلال
وبالتالي هذا المبلغ 2.4 مليار دولار
ستستفيد منه هذه الاقاليم بدرجات متفاوته
على مدى الخمس سنوات القادمه في اطار صيغه
اوليه ضمن هذا البرنامج وهذا البرنامج
ايضا يشمل نقطه اساسيه وهي انشاء منصه
كبرى للتخزين تشمل المواد الاساسيه ذاك
الاغغطيه كالخيام كالاسره وذلك في خطوه
استباقيه لمواجهه ايه كوارث اذا ما قدر
الله خلال الفتره القادمه ايضا هذا
البرنامج يعتمد ويركز بالاساس على اعاده
الاعمار واسكان المتضررين خلال المرحله
القادمه كاولويه وضمن هذا الاطار تتواصل
لحد الان في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
عمليه احصاء ومعاينه المنازل الاله للسقوط
وهي عمليه ستستمر خلال الايام التسعه
القادمه في المجمل 12 يوما ستستمر خلالها
هذه العمليه لتبدا بعدها مرحله التعويض
على مراحل وهو ما سيتم التفصيل فيه خلال
الايام القادمه هذا على مستوى التعويض
فيما يخص المنازل الاله للسقوط على مستوى
ايضا التعليم تتواصل بدرجات متفاوته من
منطقه الى اخرى قضيه التعليم هنا في
المناطق المتضرره حيث موحد خلال هذا اليوم
توزيع الكتب المدرسيه والدفاتر على
المتضررين كانت هناك خيام كانت هناك وحدات
متنقله وكان هناك ايضا نقل للتلاميذ في
المناطق الاكثر تضررا كائغيل وجوكات الى
مناطق اخرى كما هو الحال في تارودانت وفي
مراكش على مستوى تقديم الدعم الناشطين او
المحسنين نوحد تراجع في وتيره وصول
المساعدات والقوافل الى هذه المناطق
المتضرره خلال الساعات الماضيه مقارنه
بهذا الاسبوع حيث كانت وتيره التضامن
كبيره جدا الان بدات الامور تستقر بل
تنخفض في منحن يعني انخفاض نلاحظ الطرقات
لم تعد فيها تلك القوافل
بالتزامن مع ذلك يتم مواصله فتح الطرق
خاصه المتعلقه بالمسالك القرويه لان
المسالك القرويه هناك دواوير لا تزال
معزوله وزاره النقل والتجهيز كتفت من
تحركاتها حيث وصلت الان الى الرقم الذي
اعلنته بلغ تقريبا 90 في المئه وبقيت عشره
في المئه الجهد منصب من اجل فتح الطرقات
عن هذه المناطق فتح الطرقات سيوصل
المساعدات وسيمكن ايضا من فتح او القيام
بزيارات عائليه للاطمئنان على اولئك الناس
المتضررين في تلك المناطق عبد القادر
المختار الهبلاوي من مراكش شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الادرب الجاليه تعليق
العمليات العسكريه في اقليم كارابا
بمجموعه من الشروط وقادر المتحدث باسم
الوزاره انار ايفازوف ان من بين تلك
الشروط انسحاب التشكيلات المسلحه
الارمينيه من الاقليم وتسليم اسلحتها
الثقيله بالتنسيق مع قوات حفظ السلام
الروسيه
تبلغ وزاره الدفاع في جمهوريه اذربيجان
انها ستعلق الاجراءات المحليه لمكافحه
الارهاب وفقا للشروط التاليه تلقي تشكيلات
القوات المسلحه الارمينيه والجماعات
المسلحه الارمينيه غير الشرعيه الموجوده
في منطقه كراباخ بجمه
وتترك مواقعها القتاليه ومواقعها العسكريه
وينزع سلاحها بالكامل بالتوازي تسلم جميع
الاسلحه والمعدات الثقيله تنفذ العمليات
المذكوره بالتنسيق مع وحدات حفظ السلام
الروسيه
هذا وقال الرئيس لاذربيجاني الهام علي ان
اذربيجان حققت كل اهدافها وسعاده سيادتها
خلال يوم واحد في العمليه في كارابا واضاف
في خطاب ان بلاده اتخذت على الفور الخطوات
اللازمه وعاقبت العدو على النحو الصحيح
وتم الانتهاء من جميع المهام في يوم واحد
فقط وتوعد عليا من سماهم بالارهابيين
بالعقاب مؤكدا ان اي استفزاز من جهتهم
سيقابل برد لائق حسب قوله
عند الساعه الواحده من مساء اليوم اعلن عن
وقف اطلاق النار وقد التزم الطرف الاخر
بوقف اطلاق النار بشكل كامل وطبعا جاء ذلك
عقب الهجوم الذي اشتهدف اراضينا وبعد
الاعلان عن وقف اطلاق النار تم قبول
شروطنا كما وردت في الاتفاق ووفقا
لمبادئنا كما اعلنت للتو لقد حققت
اذربيجان كل اهدافها واستعادت سيادتها
خلال يوم واحد في العمليات في كاراباخ
من جهتها اعلنت تسلطته
على مقترح بعثه السلام الروسيه بوقف اطلاق
النار في الاقليم وقالت في بيان انه نظرا
للوضع الحالي ولان تحركات المجتمع الدولي
في اتجاه انهاء الحرب وايجاد حل غير كافيه
فان سلطات ارما كاراباخ تقبل باقتراح
قياده قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه بشان وقف
اطلاق النار واضاف البيان انه تم توصل الى
اتفاق لحل التشكيلات العسكريه الارمليه في
كربا في كارباخ وانسحاب الوحدات
والعسكريين والمعدات الثقيله الى ارمينيا
من جهته قال الكلب لانه ان اقليم كهرباء
خشان داخلي اذربيجاليه وان ارمينيا اعترفت
بسياده باكو عليه واضاف ان روسيا تعول على
التزام اذربيجان بوعودها بعدم استهداف
المدنيين وانه لا اساس للحديث عن تصفيات
عرقيه في اقليم كاراباخ في غضون ذلك قال
الرئيس الروسي فلادي لوسائل اعلام روسيه
ان بلاده على اتصال باطراف الصراع في
اقليم كاراباخ وقال بوتين خلال اجتماعه
بوزير الخارجيه الصيني
ان موسكو تتوقع تحقيق تسويه سلميه للوضع
في كارباخ وان قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه
تبذل قصاره جهدها لحمايه المدنيين
لعله الاستثناء جوله القتال الاحدث في
كاراباخ لم تدم طويله هذا البيجان التي
تعمل على اخضاع الجيب الانفصالي في
الاقليم علقت عملياتها العسكريه لكن بشروط
تبلغ وزاره الدفاع في جمهوريه اذربيجان
انها ستعلق الاجراءات المحليه لمكافحه
الارهاب وفقا للشروط التاليه تلقي تشكيلات
القوات المسلحه الارمينيه والجماعات
المسلحه الارمينيه غير الشرعيه الموجوده
في منطقه كراباخ بجمهوريه اذربيجان
اسلحتها وتترك مواقعها القتاليه ومواقعها
العسكريه وينزع سلاحها بالكامل بالتوازي
تسلم جميع الاسلحه والمعدات الثقيله تنفذ
العمليات المذكوره بالتنسيق مع وحدات حفظ
السلام الروسيه
روسيا هي كلمه السر في التهدئه العائده
الى كراباخ ليس لان قواتها لحفظ السلام
تدخلت للمساعده في اجلاء المدنيين من
مناطق القتال في الاقليم وانما الان اطراف
الصراع هناك قبلت مقترح قياده القوات
الروسيه بوقف لاطلاق النار والاكثر دقه ان
ارمن الاقليم من المسلحين استجابوا لشروط
باكو لكن سلطاتهم حريصه على بيان ان
الموافقه اخذت في الحسبان الوضع الحالي
وكون تحركات المجتمع الدولي لانهاء الحرب
وايجاد حل غير كافيه
ارمينيا تراقب الموقف كدابها من كثب ومع
ذلك يبدو انها لم تكن طرفا في الاتفاق
الذي راعه الروس
علمنا من الصفحات الرسميه لكرباخ انه
بواسطه روسيه قبلت سلطات الاقليم مقترحا
لبعثه حفظ السلام الروسيه بشان وقف اطلاق
النار اطلعنا على نص الاتفاق باعتبار ان
ارمينيا لم تشارك باي شكل من الاشكال في
صيغه هذا النص ولم تكن طرفا في المفاوضات
فقد اثار انتباهنا ان هذا النص يشير الى
اخراج القوات المسلحه الارمينيه المتبقيه
في الاقليم بالنسبه لنا هذا غير مفهوم
صرحنا في اكثر من مناسبه انه لا وجود
عسكريا ارمينيا هناك منذ اغسطس من عام
تطالب ارمينيا بضمانات امنيه دوليه لارمن
كاراباخ لا يجعلها ذلك في من ان من
الانتقاد الشعبي لادارتها ملف النزاع في
الاقليم
عار عليكم يصرخ هذا الرجل مخاطبا حكومه
باشنيان يشعر هؤلاء المحتاجون في ريفاند
بان السلطات بلدهم خذلت ابناء قوميتهم في
ارض سخ وهي الاسم الارمي
هناك توالت الانتكاسات الميدانيه على
الوحدات العسكريه الارمنيه امام جيش
اذربيجان والان حملت على وقف القتال وحل
نفسها وتسليم ما تملكه من معدات وسلاح
عن من بكو مراسل للجزيره عامر لافي ومن
يريفان مراسل الجزيره محمود الزئبق الدماك
عامر لافي الرئيس الاذربيجاني القى خطاب
انتصار
بالفعل عبد القادر واضح جدا ان هذا الخطاب
كان خطابا يعني يوضح حجم السعاده والغبطه
ربما انصحها وصفه الاذر بجانيه بهذه
النتائج التي تحققت بسرعه وبوقت قياسي كما
قال علي كما صرح الكثير من المسؤولين
الاذربيجانين ربما اذا اردنا اختصار هذا
الخطاب لعليه يمكن القول بان هناك ثلاث
نقاط رئيسيه الاولى وانه ثبت حقائق او
اراد ان يقول انها حقائق هي التي دفعت
اذربيجان للقيام بهذه العمليه وثبت حقائق
حاليا ناتجه عن هذه العمليه والنقطه
الثالثه هو انه ارسل رسائل مهمه ربما توضح
صوره المستقبل او كيف تريد اذربيجان لهذا
المستقبل ان يكون بدايه مع عبد القادر علي
ياه قال بان اذربيجان اجبرت على تنفيذ هذه
العمليه هو طالبه وتحدث مرارا وتكرارا مع
الارميني من اجل سحب القوات الموجوده كما
يقول بشكل غير شرعي هناك اتفاق وقع قبل
عامين وبموجب هذا الاتفاق يجب ان تنسحب
هذه القوات لكن على العكس من ذلك قال بانه
قبل بدء العمليات كان هناك 100 مدرعه
ودبابه ارمينيه موجوده في كرباخ اكثر من
200 وحده مدفعيه موجوده في كهرباء وقال
بان الالغام التي زرعت في طريق الشرطه
والقوات الاذربيجانيه هي الغام مصنوعه في
ارمينيا في عام 2021 اي انها الغام جديده
هذه الالغام تعرف الاتفاق وقع في عام 2020
وهي اهل مصنوعه في 21 فاذا هي زرعت بعد
ذلك وبدعم من ارمينيا التي قال بان هذا
الجيش زرع هناك في كهرباء بدعم كامل من
الدوله الارمنيه الامر الاخر كما قلنا
تثبيت الوضع الحالي اي انتصار سريع وجاهزه
اذربيجان للرد بسرعه على اي تجاوز ربما من
جانب القوات الارمنيه او الانفصاليين
خطاب انتصار فالوضع مغاير تماما في ريفان
محمود الزيبق بشنيان يقول لا نعلم هذا
الاتفاق وليس لدينا قوات والشارع يضغط على
برشلونه
نعم عبد القادر ما يجري هو جزء من تبادل
الاتهام بما جرى في كرباخ ما بين ارمينيا
وروسيا حقيقه مسؤولين ارمن هنا تحدثوا
اليوم وقالوا ان روسيا خذلت كرباح خذلت
أخساخ كما يسميها الارمن هنا لكن في نفس
الوقت ايضا روسيا تنقل اتهامات على حكومه
باشنيان وتكون بان هذه الحكومه هي من وقعت
هذه المعاهدات هي من اعترف
بحقيه اذربيجان
باقليم كهرباء وبالتالي فان اذربيجان تقوم
الان
بعمليه عسكريه داخل ارضها وفقا لما اعترفت
به الحكومه الارمينيه فعليا عبد القادر
الحكومه الارمينيه بالفعل اعترفت في
معاهداتها بحدود عام 91 حدود ما بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي وهذه الحدود
التي اعترفت بها ارمينيا تقول حكومه
باشميان انها اصلا تم الاعترافها عام 91
وليس الان وبالتالي
اقليم كهربائي لم يكن اصلا يوما ما جزء من
ارمينيا كان جمهوريه مستقله لم يعترف بها
اي دوله ولا حتى ارمينيا وكان لافتا انه
منذ ايام عندما انتخب رئيس جديد
من اقليم افساخ كما يسميه الارمن لم لم
يهنئ رئيس الحكومه
رئيس ارساء وقال انه امام مسؤوليه كبيره
ولا يحتاج الى تهنئه يعني كانت ربما نوع
من تكرار الاعتراف بان اذربيجان هذه الارض
اقليم كارباخ وارض اذربيجانيه ودعت ايضا
ارمينيا الارمنه في كرباخ الى التفاوض
بشكل مباشر مع اذربيجان بما يعني انها
تقول ان المشكله نوعا ما هي مشكله داخل
اذربيجان لكن الان ما يجري للارمن داخل
كاراباغ
رئيس رئيس الوزراء الارميني هو جزء من
القاء اللوم على روسيا لانها هي من نظم
هذا الاتفاق وهي من خذلل الارمن داخل
الكرباك وليس الحكومه الارنيه لان الحكومه
الارمنيه لم تكن طرفا في هذا الشان في
اريد ان اعرج على بعض التصريحات على بعض
التطورات الميدانيه عبد القادر قبل قليل
كان هناك تطور لافت على الحدود الشرقيه
لارمينيا حيث اشارت وزاره الدفاع
الارمينيه انه في الساعه العاشره ليلا
اطلق الرصاص واطلقت
النيران على مواقع ارمينيه في صوت وهي
مدينه في الشرق وفيها معبر مع اذربيجان
ومع اقليم كاراباغت بالتالي هنا نتحدث عن
تطور جديد بحيث تنتقل المعارك ما بين
اذربيجان والارمن في اقليم كاراباخ لتبدا
الاشتباكات مع القوات الارمينيه هنا وعلى
الاراضي الامينيه وهو ما كانت منه ارمينيا
دائما ان ارمينيا ليست طرفا في هذه
المعارك وتقول ان اذربيجان تحاول قدر
الامكان ان توسع هذه الحرب ارمينيا في هذا
الصراع الذي يجري الان في اقليم كارباخ
محمود الزيبق من يربان وعامر لافي من باكو
شكرا جزيلا لكم
هذا وتنتشر قوه حفظ السلام الروسيه في
اقليم كاراباخ منذ عام 2020 وتقوم هذه
القوات بمراقبه الالتزام باتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار الذي تم في نوفمبر من نفس العام بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا اتعرف اكثر على هذه
القوات في العرض التالي
عام 2020 ترافق اتفاق اطلاق النار بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا في اقليم مع شرط اساسي
ينص على نشر روسيا قوات حفظ سلام في
المنطقه تراقب مدى التزام الطرفين
بالاتفاق على اساس ذلك انتشر ما يزيد عن
1960 جنديا روسيا على طول ممر دخلت القوات
الى المنطقه حامله اسلحه خفيفه مع عدد
قليل من ناقلات الجند المدرعه قوات حفظ
السلام الروسيه تدير اكثر من عشرين نقطه
تفتيش هناك ويقيم الجنود دوريات يوميه في
اجزاء مختلفه من المنطقه لكنهم ينتقلون
الى نقاط التماس فقط عندما يتم تنبيههم من
هيئه الاركان العامه سواء في اذربيجان او
في ارمينيا لوجود تحركات عسكريه ما ويتم
تشغيل طائرات المراقبه بدون طيار التابعه
للوحده من مركز قياده روسي تركي مشترك
مكانه يقع على بعد حوالي 20 كم من نقاط
التماس بالضبط بجوار قريه في منطقه اقدام
وهي تضم عددا متساويا من القوات الروسيه
والتركيه 60 من كل جانب وبموجب الاتفاق
يضمن التفويض وجود هذه القوات لمده خمس
سنوات قابله للتمديد
[موسيقى]
الاكاديميه والباحثه المتخصصه في شؤون
القوقاز سيده دراجات زين ما الذي جعل هذه
الاشتباكات تحسم في يوم واحد فقط
نعم هذا امر مريع ان يحصل القتال اصلا حيث
يتم استخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه سواء
كان ذلك حقا ام لا عندما يكون هناك قتله
في صوف المدنيين وحتى الجنود ومن المريعه
ان يفقد الشباب حياتهم هكذا اعتقد انه في
كلا الطرفين لا يوجد رغبه وينبغي ان لا
تكون رغبه لفقدانه اخرين حياتهم اذا كان
هناك لقاء سيتم غدا نامل ان الجميع يكون
فعلا يريد ذلك هناك تحميل من قبل الجانب
الارميني لجزء من المسؤوليه لقوات حفظ
السلام او للدور الروسي فيما يجري في
اقليم كندا ماذا عن هذا البعد في فهم ما
جرى هذه المره وتوقف الاشتباكات وانتهائها
في يوم واحد فقط
هذا سؤال يعتمد على معرفه دقائق الامور
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه دائما موجوده في
هذه النزاعات في مناطق تعتبرها الروسيه
بانها دول الجوار المباشر لها هي دائما
لها وجود في هذه الاماكن وفي الماضي اعتقد
ان الارمنين اعتقدوا وايضا بالتاكيد
الاذربيجانيون كذلك اعتبروا ان الروسي
يقفون الى جانب
الارمنيين الان ما نراه هو انه وبالرغم من
ان الروس يسعدهم ان يكونوا حاضرين لا يبدو
انهم راغبين في الانحياز الى طرف دون
الاخر هذا ربما يكون امرا مزعجا حقيقه
لارمن اليوم لانهم يشعرون
انهم لم يعودوا يحظوا بالحمايه من جانب
واحد من القوات الروسيه والحضور الروسي في
المنطقه الشروط التي على اساسها تم ايقاف
هذه الاشتباكات وهي خروج القوات المسلحه
بما فيها الارمينيه كما يقول الجانب
الاذربيجاني والتسليم السلاح والتمهيد
لدخول في عمليه سلميه هل معنى ذلك حل
جدري لهذه القضيه في اقليم كنباخ
صعوبه بمكان ان نعرف هل ان هذا حل ام لا
لانه في خاتمه المطاف هذا ما يطالب به
الاذربيجانيون ولا ادري الى اي مدى
الارمينيون ام ماذا سيحصلون بالمقابل لكن
ما هو مثير للاهتمام على الاقل ان
[موسيقى]
اذربيجانيين يريدون
الحديثه مع ممثلين جولد
بدلا من الحديث دائما الى
المتحدثين الاتينا من ارمينيا نفسها اذا
الارتقاء بهؤلاء بحد ذاته سيكون شيئا
جديدا واذا ما حدث ربما يكون خطوه باتجاه
افضل اذا ما تم فعلا هذا امر لا نعرفه
حقيقه الان هل ما زالت روسيا تلعب دور
الوسيط بين الطرفين شاهدنا في الايام
الماضيه مثلا يربان رفضت اجراء مناورات
عسكريه مع موسكو وقامت بها مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي هل ما زالت
موسكو تلعب دور الوسيط بين الطرفين ام ان
الحسابات اختلفت
[موسيقى]
هذا غير من حسابات الروس على الاقل لانك
بامكانك ان تتظاهر نعم نقول نحن لا نريد
الروس سنحاز الى الامريكيين هذا ليس حقيقه
لان هناك وجود كبير لروسيا في القوقاز في
جورجيا وفي ارمينيا وبالطبع
اذربيجان واني غورني قرباغ اذا هذا لن
يكون سهلا للارمانيين ان يتخلصوا منه كوضع
قائم لكنهم يفقدون الصبر يريدون رؤيه
الامور تسير لصالحهم ولكن ذلك لم يحصل في
الايام القليله الماضيه لذا نامل ان نوع
من الاحتواء والاستيعاب شكرا القدره على
الاحلال السلامه الروس لن يغادروا المنطقه
ولن
يترك القوق
ادركنا الوقت
المتخصصه في شؤون القوقاز كنت معنا من
لندن
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
في اوكرانيا تسببت في معاناه لا حدود لها
فان استمرار يهدد بمزيد من التصعيد الخطير
واضاف خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا ان الامم
المتحده تعمل مع جميع الاطراف من اجل ضمان
صادرات امنه من الحبوب والاسمده من روسيا
واوكرانيا وتناولت الجلسه سبل حفظ السلام
والامن في اوكرانيا كما شهدت خلافات بين
الولايات المتحده والمانيا من جهه اللتين
عملتها على منح الرئيس الاوكراني
فرصه القاء كلمه امام اعضاء المجلس وروسيا
التي اعترضت على ذلك من جهه اخرى
هذا وكان الرئيس الاوكراني
قد قال امام مجلس الامن انما وصفه
بالعدوان الروسي غير مبرر واجرامي يهدف
الى الاستيلاء على اراضي اوكرانيا
ومواردها
ممتن لجميع الذين اعترفوا بالعدوان الروسي
باعتباره انتهاكا لميثاق الامم المتحده
اوكرانيا تمارس حقها في الدفاع عن نفسها
ومساعده اوكرانيا بالسلاح وفرض العقوبات
على روسيا والضغط عليها كلها عوامل تدخل
في حق الدفاع عن النفس
قال وزير الخارجيه ان الرئيس الاوكراني
وقع مرسوما يحضر المفاوضات مع حكومه بوتين
وان الغرب لم يحرك ساكنا واضاف لابروف
امام جلسه بمجلس الامن ان الاطراف الواقعه
على اتفاق ميسك العام الماضي باستثناء
الرئيس بوتين لا تعتزم تطبيق هذه الوثيقه
وان الغرب تجاهل اتفاق مصر ولذلك فهو
مسؤول عن هذه الازمه كما قال لافروف ان
الغرب لم يتعرض مطلقا لاسباب هذه الازمه
وانه بقياده الولايات المتحده يلجا الى
المعايير والقواعد بشكل انتقائي
هذا وتهم وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن روسيا بارتيكا بجرائم حرب وجرائم
ضد الانسانيه يوميا في اوكرانيا وقال امام
جلسه بمجلس الامن بشان الحرب على اوكرانيا
ان روسيا مزقت لاكثر من عام ونصف ميثاق
الامم المتحده والاعلان العالمي لحقوق
الانسان واضاف انه من الصعب تصور دوله
تظهر المزيد من الازدراء للامم المتحده
مثل روسيا التي قال انها تواصل الانخراط
في التهديدات النوويه وتنشر اسلحتها في
بيلاروسيا وطالب بلينكن بضروره ارسال
اشاره واضحه لروسيا ولمن وصفهم بالمعتدين
بان المجتمع الدولي سيتصدى لهم مؤكدا في
المقابل ان الاوكرانيين لن يستسلموا وعند
الولايات المتحده ايضا لن تستسلم ولن
تتخلى عنهم
اعلن جيش الاوكراني انه استهدف مركز قياده
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في شبه جزيره
القرم وفي خرسون جنوبا قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان قوه خاصه دمرت ثلاثه زوارق
حربيه روسيه اثناء ابحارها في نهر دنيفر
بمنطقه خرسون وكانت القوات الروسيه قد
شنتها هجمات صاروخيه واسعه على مناطق في
اقليم خرسون خلفت قتلى ودمارا وفق السلطات
الاوكرانيه
في خضم مسارها الروتيني ويومياتها
المعتاده يحدث ان تسجل حرب اوكرانيا بين
حين واخر وقائع جديده قد لا تعرف قيمتها
العسكريه من عدمها وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اعلنت في بيان استهداف مركز
قياده اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في شبه
جزيره القرم وسبق البيان الاوكراني اعلان
حاكم مدينه سيفا ستوبول في القرم ان
الدفاعات الروسيه احبطت هجوما صاروخيا على
المدينه التي تضم مقر الاسطول وقد كثف
الجيش الاوكراني في الاسابيع الاخيره
هجماته في القرم باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار وزوارق مسيره وعمليات انزال لضرب
قواعده وسفن روسيه الضغط الاوكراني امتد
جنوبا اذا اعلنت كييف ان قوه خاصه تابعه
لجهاز الامن المركزي اعترضت ثلاثه زوارق
حربيه روسيه ودمرتها وهي تبحر في نهر
الدينيبرو باقليم خرسون في اقليم خرسون
ايضا تعرضت مناطق في وقت سابق لهجوم روسي
واسع قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انه نفذ
بمئات القذائف الصاروخيه وخلف قتلى وجرحى
مدنيين والحق اضرارا كبيره بالمنازل
والمنشات الطبيه والتعليميه
وعن المعارك في اقليم دونيسك شرقيه
اوكرانيا عرضت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقاطع
لما قالت انها ضربه صاروخيه دمرت قوات
اللواء الخامس والثلاثين من مشاه البحريه
الاوكرانيه
الى السودان حيث قال مراسل الجزيره ان
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع تبادل القصف
المدفعي العنيف وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان حول
موقعهما بمحيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني وكذلك القصر الجمهوري وافاد
مراسل الجزيره بان مدفعيه الجيش توالى
قصفها على مواقع تابعه للدعم السريع
بمناطق مختلفه في العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت
مصادر محليه للجزيره انه سمع عدوي قصف
مدفعي عنيف ومتتال من مواقع قوات الدعم
السريع شرقي الخرطوم باتجاه القياده
العامه للجيش تزامن ذلك مع سماع اصوات
لاطلاق نار وسط مدينه ام درمان
من جهتها قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان
قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت منطقه الاضيه
بولايه غرب كردفان حيث دارت معارك عنيفه
بالقرب من حاميه الجيش العسكري وبحسب
المصادر فقد تمكن الجيش من تدمير خمس
سيارات عسكريه ومطارده قوات الدعم السريع
خارج مدينه القضيه كما افادت مصادر عسكريه
للجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني بوسط
الخرطوم من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه
واشارت المصادر الى ان الجيش تمكن من صد
الهجوم واستولى على عدد من الاليات
الحربيه
في تطور لافت نقلت شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه عن مصدر عسكري اوكراني قوله ان
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه هي على الارجح
من تقف وراء هجمات غامضه بطائرات مسيره ضد
قوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذا الشهر واضافت الشبكه في تحقيق
مطول ان 6 غارات بطائرات من دون طيار
استهدفت في الثامن من الشهر الجاري قافله
من الشاحنات بين ام درمان والخرطوم فيما
استهدفت ثمان هجمات اخرى مركبات ومبانيه
ومسلحين داخل ام درمان حيث توجد قوات
الدعم السريع المدعومه من مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه
رحابه الخارجيه السعوديه بما وصفتها
بالنتائج الايجابيه للنقاشات الجاده بشان
التوصل الى خريطه طريق لدعم مسار السلام
في اليمن والتي عقدت في الرياض بين فريق
التواصل والتنسيق السعودي ووفد من جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين بحضور وفد عملي كما
اشادت الوزاره بمضامين اللقاء وزير الدفاع
السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان بوفد انصار
الله الحوثيين الذي زار المملكه مؤخرا
وقال وزير الدفاع السعودي على منصه اكس
انه اكد خلال اللقاء بالوفد ووقوف المملكه
مع اليمن وشعبه وحرصها على تشجيع الاطراف
اليمنيه على الجلوس الى طاوله الحوار
للتوصل الى حل سياسي شامل ودائم في اليمن
تحت اشراف الامم المتحده
من جهده اوضح الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
السعودي خالد بطرفي ان المفاوضات المتعلقه
بالازمه في اليمن تسير وفق مسارين احدهما
يملي يمني والثاني بين الرياض وصنعاء
واشار بطرف الى ان الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل
اليه بين السعوديه وايران ساعد في تسهيل
الوصول الى المرحله الراهنه
مسار يتعلق بالازمه اليمنيه اليمنيه
والمملكه في هذه الحاله
تتواصل مع جميع الاطراف ومنها المكون
الحوثي
لوضع خريطه الطريق يتفق عليها الجميع فيما
بعد لمسار السلام المسار الاخر هو في
تامين الحدود الجنوبيه وهذا له علاقه
مباشره مع الطرف الحوثي او وقت صنعاء
تبادل الاسرى من الطرفين انا اعتقد ان
الاتفاق الذي تم ايران كان له دور كبير في
تيسير هذا الملف
والتسريعه حسب معلوماتي ان ايران وجهت
الحوثيين بان خيار السلام اصبح والخيار
الوحيد وان عليهم التفاهم مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والتحالف العربي مع
اشقائهم اليمنيين في ذلك هذا ساعد الى حد
كبير ايضا التوقف الدعم الذي كان يص لهم
سواء من حزب الله او من ايران او من غيرها
من الجهات سواء من خلال ضبط
المراقبه والتفتيش في البحر الاحمر وبحر
العرب
والخليج العربي او توقف هذه الجهات عن دعم
الحوث بالسلاح
قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيان انه ناقش عده قضايا مع نظيره
العماني بدر البوسعيدي خلال لقائه في
نيويورك واضاف في حسابه على منصه اكس ان
مبادره السلطان نعمان لعوده كافه الاطراف
الى التزاماتها في الاتفاق النووي لا تزال
على الطاوله واكد عبد الله ان طهران تسير
في الطريق الدبلوماسي لتحقيق المصالح
الوطنيه حسب تعبيره
قال انور مستشار الرئيس الاماراتي ان
اتفاقات ابرهام ناجحه وبانها استمرت على
المستوى الاستراتيجي بغض النظر عما يراس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واضاف ان اتفاقات
ابرهام لم تصمم لحل القضيه الفلسطينيه
واضاف خلال مشاركته في القمه العالميه
الاولى للشرق الاوسط المنعقده على هامش
اجتماعات الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
انه كان هناك نفوذ على الفلسطينيين وانه
تم اعطائهم شيكا على بياض لكنهم لم يفعلوا
اي شيء بحسب تعبيره
يتواصل تدفق اللاجئين بشكل يومي في جزيره
لانفيدوزا الجنوبي ايطاليا وتقول السلطات
الايطاليه انها تقوم بتسريع نقلهم الى
اماكن
صباح اخر في ميناء الانفيدوزا يصل معه
قارب اخر وفوج جديد
ينضم هؤلاء الى الاف اتوا قبلهم منذ ايام
لا يطول بقاؤهم هنا اكثر من ساعات قبل
نقلهم الى مكان اخر وصل الى الجزيره
10,000 شخص خلال الاسبوع الثاني من سبتمبر
ياتي اغلبهم من دول جنوب الصحراء وتستغرق
الرحله يومين من السواحل التونسيه اغلب
الواصلين بين خمسه وعشرين وخمسه وثلاثين
عاما
بعيدا عن اعين السكان وشواطئ المصطافين
يقع المخيم المكان الذي يضم حاليا مئات
الاشخاص يمنع الدخول اليه
هو اننا تلقينا عددا كبيرا من اللاجئين في
يوم واحد ساعدنا اكثر من 100 قارب وصلوا
الى السواحل هنا بمساعده البحريه
الايطاليه ونتوقع وصول المزيد
تهدف الحكومه الايطاليه حاليا الى تسريع
تسجيل ونقل اللاجئين فيما لا يزيد على
يومين او ثلاثه
ووعدت بايجاد حلول لتقليل عدد الواصلين
في بحث عن حياه اخرى لمن وصل تدور الحياه
هنا كما هي الجزيره التي تعتمد السياحه
مصدرا تخشى تاثير ما يجري
ضد اللاجئين لكن لا يمكننا ان نستمر في
استقبال المئات كل يوم نساعد من نستطيع
لكن الحل في يد السياسيين جزيرتنا ليست
مكانا لاقامتهم والموسم السياحي يتاثر بكل
ما يجري
حساب الجغرافيا اهم ما في هذه المعادله مع
خليط من السياسه والاقتصاد والمصالح وفي
افق البحر الفاصل بين الضفتين هدوء حتى
اشعار اخر
على عتبات الجزيره الاقرب الى افريقيا يقف
هذا الباب المفتوح باب اوروبا كما يطلق
عليه ليكون اول ما يراه الواصلون الى هنا
حاملين معهم الام الرحله وامال المستقبل
عبد الله الشامي الجزيره لمبيدوزا جنوب
ايطاليا
مستمرون معكم في الحصاد وفي العناوين
بداوا انشائي سياج عازل في درن الليبيه
حول المنطقه الاكثر تضررا من السيول
السلطات تؤكد ان الهدف هو تسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ والحمايه من او بيئه محتمله
والجزيره ترصد احوال الناجين من الفيضانات
تسارع عمليته ايواء المنكوبين من زلزال
الحوز في المغرب والديوان الملكي يعلن
تخصيص اثني عشر مليار دولار للمرحله
الاولى من اعاده اعمار المناطق المتضرره
بعد مواجهات عسكريه استمرت يوما واحدا
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار في اقليم كاراباخ
يقول ان اذربيجان استعادت سيادتها
وبشينيان يدعو المجتمع الدولي لتوفير
ضمانات امنيه لسكان الاقليم
[موسيقى]
اذا نعود ونبدا بالمشهد في الشرقيه
الليبيه في هذه الساعه فقد اعلنت السلطات
تقسيم مدينه درنه حسب الاضرار التي لحقت
باحيائها واخلاء الاحياء الاكثر تضررا من
سكانها وذلك لتسهيل عمل فرق الانقاذ
وحمايه الناجين فيما اعلنت وكاله الانباء
الليبيه البدء في اقامه سياج عازل حول
المنطقه المنكوبه في المدينه في غضور ذلك
تتواصل جهود البحث عن المفقودين ومحاولات
انتشار جثث الضحايا فيما تستمر اعمال
تنظيف وتعقيم شوارع المدينه من جانبها
اعلنت لجنه الاستجابه للطوارئ مشاركه 14
فريق انقاذ بينها 10 من الخارج كما بدات
الفرق الطبيه حمله تطعيمات للاطباء
والناجين في محاوله لمنع انتشار الامراض
في المدينه المنكوبه
انا فقط اظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه مزيدا من
الدمار الذي وقع في مناطق شرقيه ليبيا
نتيجه الاعصار دانيال حيث سويت قرى
باكملها في الاثناء قالت غرفه عمليات
الطوارئ صحه المجتمع في ليبيا انها ستقسم
مدينه درنه الى ثلاث مناطق لتسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ والاسعاف
[موسيقى]
لم يستفق الشرق الليبي بعد من هول الاعصار
دانيال ومات له من سيول جرفت مناطق واسعه
بشكل شبهي يومي يتم الكشف عن المزيد من
الاضرار التي خلفتها الكارثه
تشير احدث المعطيات ان قرا باكملها محيت
من الخريطه في ليبيا كقريه المخيلي
الواقعه بين طبرق وبنغازي كما تظهر صور
اقمار صناعيه ماذا حل بالقريه قبل وبعد
الاعصار والفيضان ليتكشف حجم الدمار الضرر
يمتد بشكل اكثر وضوحا ويتبدى في دارنا
غرفه عمليات طوارئ صحه المجتمع قالت انها
تعمل على تحديد ثلاث مناطق جغرافيه في
المدينه بحسب حجم التاثر
المنطقه الاولى وهي المنطقه المتضرره التي
لا يمكن العيش فيها وبالتالي تبرز الحاجه
لاجلاء السكان منها عدا فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف وتتشكل من وسط مدينه درنه
المنطقه الثانيه وهي المنطقه الهشه التي
غمرتها المياه ويشكل العيش فيها خطوره على
السكان تقع هذه المنطقه في بعض شوارع محله
الجبيله والمغار المنطقه الثالثه وهي
القابله للعيش في حي باب شيخ الغربي وشيح
الشرقي وباب الطبرق والساحل الشرقي
[موسيقى]
وبعد اكثر من اسبوع على فيضانات مدينه
درنه ما زالت المدينه تحصي ضحاياها من
قتلى ومفقودين وبينما تتواصل عمليه
الانقاذ تتراجع الامال في ايجاد ناجين حيث
تقوم فرق البحث باستخراج الجثث ويثير هذا
الامر مخاوف صحيه في ظل الاعلام عن اصابات
في صفوف الجيش وفرق الانقاذ باعراض
الاسهال والقيء وغيرهما
من علي يتبين هول الماساه فهذا ما تبقى من
مدينه درنه
غير سيل ملامحها تماما
بعد اكثر من اسبوع على الكارثه يواصل
الناجون احصاء خساراتهم وهي فادحه فادحه
جدا
الوجع الممتد في المدينه يكتب على الجدران
غير بعيد من الركام تحولت هذه الخيمه الى
مقرها
لكن من يعزي من فما من احد منهم لم يترك
الموت باب بيته جميعهم مكلومون
لا
اله الا الله طارق فقد زوجته وابنائه
الثلاثه وعشرين اخرين من اقاربه
مصيبه مصيبه
بنتي الكبيره الثانيه لعلم الحيوان
وفقدت ولدي كليه هندسه يكمل شهر اربعه
القادم يعني
في هذه المدينه المنكوبه
بحثا عن المفقودين تواصل فرق الانقاذ
المحليه والدوليه ازاله الركعه لكن دون
امل تقريبا في الوصول الى ناجين
وحدها الجثه هي التي تخرج من بين الركام
فرصه وجود ناجين ضعيفه لكن الامل في الله
ان شاء الله ولازلنا في طور البحث عن
الجثث وعن المفقودين
العمل كبير والله
هكذا تحولت البيوت الى مقابر لسكانها
وليست وحدها في ذلك
بحر المدينه غدا وجه ماساتها الاخر اليه
حمل السيل كل ما صادفه في طريقه
يقوم هؤلاء الغواصون القادمون من تونس
بعمل مظن لاستخراج الجثث لكن المهمه معقده
معظم الجثث عالق تحت الصخور وداخل
السيارات
جثث الاخرى ما زالت في هذا البحر وقد لا
يتم اخراجها ابدا بسبب عظم الكارثه وقله
ان كانت
لكن يخشى ان تجر الكوارث بعضها بعضها فثمت
مخاوفه من حدوث مضاعفات وبائيه بسبب
مخلفات الفيضان
هكذا بدا ان عجله الحياه قد توقفت او كادت
في درنا رغم كل شيء لا تخلو المدينه من
رسائل الامل التي تبشر بالنجاه ومن بين
الركام يتطلع ابنائها الى تعافي مدينتهم
وقلوبهم
محمد البقالي الجزيره
درنا شرقي ليبيا
وفي غضون ذلك تتواصل بميناء درنه عمليات
استخراج الجثث من عرض البحر مراسل للجزيره
تامر الصمادي وطلعنا على اخر مشاهداته من
هناك قبل بدء قرار السلطات الصحيه وقفه
عمل الصحفيين في المناطق المنكوبه جراء
الفيضانات التي اجتاحت المدينه مؤخرا
هذه واحده من جثث كثيره تم انتشالها خلال
الساعات الماضيه من البحر هذا البحر الذي
التهم الكثير من سكان المدينه المتضرره
بفعل الفيضانات اعمال الانقاذ تتواصل بشكل
مستمر لاسيما في المناطق التي يعني ضربها
الاعصار بقوه تلك المركبات كما تشاهدون هي
لفرق متخصصه تعمل على طول الشواطئ
المنتشره على بحر درنه وعمليات عزل
المدينه بدات تتواصل وتستمر الحديث عن هذا
السياج مثلا الذي سوف
يحيط بكل المناطق المدمره والمنكوبه لا
سيما عند منطقه الوادي وادي دارنا
بالاضافه الى حي الصحابه الذي بات اثرا
بعد عين والذي تواصل فيه الفرق الصحيه
القيام باعمال متواصله للوصول الى الجثث
السلطات قسمت المدينه خلال الساعات
الماضيه الى ثلاثه نتحدث عن القسم الف وهو
الاكثر دمارا والذي ستبدا فيه السلطات
باخلاء من تبقى من سكان على قيد الحياه
ليتسنى للفرق الصحيه القيام باعمالها
وانتشال ما يمكن من جثث الوضع كارثي
للغايه مع مرور الوقت الوضع صعب جدا
ودائره الامل تضيق لا سيما فيما يخص
العثور على احياء وفقا للسلطات الصحيه في
المدينه تابرس نادي الجزيره درنح
في الساعات الماضيه في هذا اليوم من
متابعات وجهود من طرابلس معنا من هناك
مراسل للجزيره احمد خليفه اذا احمد عن
الساعات الماضيه اهم ما تم فيها من جهود
المتابعه للوضع في المناطق المنكوبه في
ليبيا
ابرز ما ورد او ما حدث في الساعه الماضيه
تحديدا عبد القادر هو ما اعلنه رئيس
المركز الليبي لمكافحه الامراض في ليبيا
حيدر السائح الذي قال فيها المؤتمر الصحفي
اليومي للفريق الحكومي للطوارئ والاستجابه
السريعه انه ليس هناك ما يدعو للقلق من
حدوث الاوبئه في مدينه درنه وقال ان هذا
ليس امرا واردا بالمره وليست هناك اي
تخوفات واكد ايضا ان الجثث الموجوده في
المدينه وان كانت بكميات كبيره لكن الجثث
بطبيعه الحال وبشكل علمي لا تنقل الامراض
ولا تنقل الاوبئه
بالمره وذكر ان اي فيروس موجود في جسم
الانسان هذا الفيروس ينتهي تماما بعد موت
هذا الشخص ايضا
قال اذا لدينا تخوفات فقط وقلق عميق جدا
من مياه الابار الجوفيه تعرف عبد القادر
على سبيل المثال ان السيول اجتاحت بقوه
مدينه درنه ما اسهم في تدمير امدادات
المياه مياه الشرب وايضا امدادات مياه
الصرف الصحي وبالتالي هناك تخوفات لدى
المركز الليبي لمكافحه الامراض من اختلاط
الابار ابار المياه الجوفيه بمياه الصرف
الصحي وهذا فيه خطر على صحه الانسان
وتحديدا مساله التلوث والنزلات المعويه
لذلك قال لدينا قلق كبير من هذه النقطه
ولذلك قال نحذر السكان وما زلنا نحذرهم من
ان يكون الماء الذي يشربونه ماء نقي وما
قد خضع للتحليل او يشربون المياه المعلبه
والمعبئه مسبقا في زجاجات وليس المياه
مياه الابار الجوفيه التي يعتمد عليها
الكثيرون في منطقه الجبل الاخضر فيما
يتعلق بعمليه الشرب ايضا قال حيدر السايح
ان قال بعد ان حدثت هذه السيول اكتشفنا ان
هناك الكثير من البرك في مياه في مياه
مدينه درنه وهذه البرك بطبيعه الحال
تنقل الامراض تحديدا مرض الكوليرا وايضا
مرض التيفود ولذلك قال سارعنا الى منح
التطعيمات الوقائيه للفرق فرق الانقاذ
وايضا للمواطنين في مدينه درنه وللاهالي
وهناك اولويه للنساء والاطفال وقال لدينا
الان اكثر من ثلاثه الاف عنصر من عناصر
الانقاذ قد تم تطعيمهم لمواجهه اي عدوى
محتمله لكنه استبعد تماما انتشار الاوبئه
والامراض في مدينه درنه وقال ان هذا لن
يحدث احمد خليفه من طرابلس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلن المغرب اعتماد 120 مليار درهم بما
يساوي 12 مليار دولار لبرنامج اعاده ايواء
المتضررين من زلزال الحوز ويستهدف
البرنامج نحو اربعه ملايين ومئتي الف نسمه
على مدى خمس سنوات وخلال جلسه عمل مخصصه
لمتابعه تنفيذ عمليه اعاده اعمار المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال دعا العاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس الى تفعيل الرؤيه التي
اعدت لاعاده اواء المتضررين وتشجيع
الانشطه الاقتصاديه بجميع الاقاليم
المتضرره من الزلزال وشدد العاهل المغربي
على اهميه التركيز على احتياجات المتضررين
من اجل تقديم الحلول الملائمه لهم من
ايلاء الاهميه للبعد البيئي وانماط عيش كل
منطقه
وعن الامان للمعقوده على الوصول الى احياء
تحت الانقاذ تواصل فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه
عمليات البحث اثرا زلزال اقليم الحوز الذي
وقع في الثامن من الشهر الجاري وقالت
وزاره الصحه المغربيه ان عدد الجرح الذين
تكفلت بهم وزاره الصحه بلغ سته عشر الفا
76 شخصا بينهم الف ومائه وخمسه اشخاص
اصابتهم خطيره ونحو
492 اصابتهم طفيفه كما اشارت الوزاره الى
ان عدد المصابين في المستشفيات يصل حاليا
الى
375 بينهم 54 في اقسام العنايه المركزه في
غضون ذلك بدات السلطات المغربيه عمليه
احصاء المباني المتضرره تمهيدا لاعاده
الاعمار
هذا واكدت وزاره التجهيز والنقل المغربيه
ان مصالحها الاقليميه بالحوز تمكنت من فتح
نحو 90% من الطرق القرويه المغلقه الرابطه
بين الطرق الرئيسيه والتجمعات السكنيه
النائيه واوضح المدير الاقليمي للوزاره
باقليم الحوز هشام فريندي للجزيره ان
الفرق الميدانيه التابعه للوزارات تركز
حاليا على فتح الطرق بالمناطق المنكوبه
كان اعداد واحد برنامج تدخل على مستوى
مركز القياده بالعماله ومن خلاله صخره
الوزاره الاليات والموارد البشريه
القرويه التي تؤدينا للضواوير لفك العزات
تاع الدواوير الحمد لله اليوم تقريبا تم
كنا من فتح واحد 90% او نسبه 90% ديالنا
في
تنستمر تنوصلوا العمل ديالنا
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الان الى مبنى الامم المتحده في
نيويورك وهذه النافذه مع خديجه خديجه
شكرا عبد القادر اهلا بك وبمشاهدين الى
هذه النافذه من مقر الامم المتحده من
نيويورك
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرج قال ان الحرب في اوكرانيا تسببت في
معاناه لا حدود لها
وان استمرارها يهدد بمزيد من التصعيد
الخطير واضاف غوتيريش خلال جلسه لمجلس
الامن الدولي بشان تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا ان الامم المتحده تعمل مع جميع
الاطراف من اجل ضمان صادرات صادرات امنه
من الحبوب والاسمده من روسيا واوكرانيا
وتناولت الجلسه سبل حفظ السلام والامن في
اوكرانيا كما شهدت خلافات بين الولايات
المتحده والمانيا من جهه اللتين عملتها
على منح الرئيس الاوكراني
الكلمه فرصه التحدث والقاء كلمه امام
اعضاء مجلس الامن وبين روسيا التي اعترضت
على ذلك من جهه اخرى
وكان الرئيس الاوكراني
قد قال في هذه الجلسه امام مجلس الامن
الدولي قال ان ما وصفه او ما وصفه
بالعدوان الروسي غير مبرر واجرامي ويهدف
الى الاستيلاء على اراضي اوكرانيا وعلى
مواردها بالقوه
ممتن لجميع الذين اعترفوا بالعدوان الروسي
باعتباره انتهاكا لمثاق الامم المتحده
اوكرانيا تمارس حقها في الدفاع عن نفسها
ومساعده اوكرانيا بالسلاح وفرض العقوبات
على روسيا والضغط عليها كلها عوامل تدخل
في حق الدفاع عن النفس
خرجت الروسيس
اتهم الدول الاوروبيه الموقعه على معاهده
مينسك التي سعت لانهاء الحرب في اقليم
دومباز بانها وقعت على هذه المعاهده دون
وجود نيه لديها للالتزام بهذه الاتفاقيه
او المعاهده واضاف لبروف ان روسيا وحدها
هي من التزم بالمعاهده حسب تعبيره
في عام 2015 تم التوصل الى معاهده مينيسك
وتبنيها عبر قرار من مجلس الامن الدولي
وفي العام الماضي جميع الموقعين على
معاهده مينيسك
وانا اتحدث هنا عن ميركل وهولاند
وبروشينكو صرحوا علنا وبنبره من السرور
بان ليس لديهم النيه لتنفيذها كانوا
ببساطه يحاولون كسب الوقت لرفع قدرات
اوكرانيا العسكريه واعطائها الاسلحه كي
تستخدمها ضد روسيا
من جهته قل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
قال ان روسيا ترتكب جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه في اوكرانيا بشكل شبه يومي
واضاف في كلمه له بمجلس الامن الدولي ان
موسكو تواصل الانخراطه في التهديدات
النوويه وتنشر اسلحتها في بيلاروسيا
الغزو الروسي في حد ذاته ينتهك الركيزه
الاساسيه لميثاق الامم المتحده الا وهي
احترام سياده جميع الدول ووحده اراضيها
موسكو ترتكب جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه في اوكرانيا بشكل شبه يومي كما
تواصل تهديداتها النوويه المتهوره واعلنت
نشر اسلحتها في بيلاروسيا الى جانب ذلك
فهي تستخدم اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في
اوروبا وموظفيها درعا لعدوانها
وتنضم الينا من الامم المتحده مراسله
الجزيره بسان ابو كيك بيسان لو نلخص اهم
نجاح اليوم من كلمات واجتماعات ولقاءات في
هذا اليوم من اعمال الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده تفضلي
ربما نعم خديجه ربما هذه الجلسه جلسه مجلس
الامن حول اوكرانيا كانت الحدث الابرز
التي الذي شهدناه اليوم هذه طبعا جلسات
متعدده عقدها مجلس الامن على مدار
العامين تقريبا الماضيين في مسعى لحل
الحرب في اوكرانيا وايقافها ولكن اليوم
اللافت هو حضور الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمنسكي بنفسه ليتهم هذا المجلس والامم
المتحده بالتقاعس عن القيام بدورها في
انهاء هذه الحرب طبعا موجها اتهاماته الى
روسيا بالقول بانه لا يمكن لدوله تعتدي
على سياده دوله اخرى ان تتمتع بحق النقد
الفيتو ولذا لم تتمكن الامم المتحده ولا
مجلس الامن من
على اي شيء لايقافي هذه الحرب واللافت
انها ربما المره الاولى التي يكون بها
زيلينسكي بهذا القرب من مسؤولين روس رغم
ان وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لم يكن في القاعه
حيندثكي كان قد غادر حين اتى لافروف الذي
هو بنفسه اتهم الغرب بمحاوله انقلاب لوضع
رئيس محسوب على العربه في اوكرانيا وشهدت
طبعا الجلسه هذا
المحاوله من السفير الروسيه دائم لدى
الامم المتحده فاسلين بنز
باعتراده على اعطاء زيلينس في كلمه بدايه
الجلسه فرد عليها رئيس المجلس وهو رئيس
وزراء البانيا بالقول انه لو توقف الحرب
باوكرانيا فستنتهي هذه المشكله وكان هناك
شد ورد ما بين الطرفين طبعا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ايضا وجهها
اتهاماته لروسيا بهذه الحرب امين عام
الامم المتحده تحدث عن خرق وانتهاك ميثاق
الامم المتحده لذا كانت جلسه محتده
بمشاركه لاول مره ربما رئيس اوكرانيا
واتهامه الامم المتحده بالتقاعس بالقيام
بدورها لانهاء هذه الحرب خديجه
نعم بيسان ابو كويك شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه التفاصيل وتنضم الينا هنا في
الاستوديو في استوديو تغطيه بالامم
المتحده الينا فيتونان وزيره الخارجيه
الفنلنديه اهلا وسهلا بك
طبعا في فنلندا لديها ربما هي البلد
الاوروبي الذي لديه اطول حدود مع روسيا
ربما
1300 واكثر من 1300 كيلومتر انضمامكم الان
الى الناتو هل يشعركم بالامان هل انتم
الان تشعرون بالحمايه والامان من اي
تهديدات روسيه
نعم حقيقه نحن نمتلك اطول حدود مع روسيا
في اوروبا اكثر من 1300 كيلو متر حقيقه
وطبعا دائما استثمرنا في
الدفاع عن بلدنا علينا ان ندافع عن بلدنا
ضد اي عدوان من روسيا او غزو حتى من ايام
الاتحاد
السوفيتي والان وطبعا وفي الماضي فعلنا
ذلك وفي المستقبل سنفعل ذلك انضمامنا الى
النيتو يشعرنا بالامان لكن ايضا سنوفر نحن
ايضا بعض الامان للتحالف
ما نوع الامان الذي تقدمونه انتم للتحالف
كما تقولين الان للحلف
جميل ولكن انتم لاحظتم ربما خلال سنه ونصف
من هذه الحرب ان النيتو لم يتحرك بشكل
مباشر في اوكرانيا
فهل هذا يشاركم بالقلق ام ربما بالامان
اكثر
بما انه انتم الان تشعرون بالامان مع
انضمامكم لحلف الناتو لكن النيتو فعليا لم
يقدم لاوكرانيا ما كانت تتطلع اليه
اوكرانيا
موجوده في الان وفي المستقبل على طريق
الانضمام الى ناتو الامر لا يتعلق بالقدره
العسكريه لكن يتعلق بحكم القانون
والديمقراطيه وغير ذلك وايضا من المهم
عندما تتطلعوا اوكرانيا الانضمام الاتحاد
الاوروبي على اتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو ان
يعززا ذلك هي ليست اتحادات لبلبان تتوسع
بالقوه بل هي هي بلدان اللي فيها شعوب
وفيها الديمقراطيات وهذا ينطبق على فنلندا
كما ينطبق على السويد وعندما تقدمنا بطلب
الانضمام ومنذ فتره طويله حقيقه الانضمام
اتحاد الاوروبي ونحن نسعى لان يكون العالم
كله
يقوم على اساس استثباب حكم القانون وهذا
مهم في اسبوع الامم المتحده هذا
الوزيره انتم ذهبتم الى حد بناء جدار عازل
بينكم وبين روسيا على الحدود هل هناك ما
يستدعي ذلك خصوصا انه ليس هناك قوات روسيه
يعني بشكل مباشر على الحدود على خط الحدود
الفاصل بينكم وبين روسيا
هل كان هناك ضروره لهذا الجدار العازل
[موسيقى]
الجدار سيكون سياجا حقيقه ضد العمليات
الهجينه التي مررنا بها ليس فقط في فنلندا
لكن في بلدان اوروبي اخرى
وغيرها راينا كيف ان هناك من يسعى
لنيل صفه اللجوء يتم دفعهم عبر الحدود نحن
ملزمون وراغبون في ان نلتزم بالاتفاقيات
الدوليه بقبول اللاجئين طبعا ليس من
الصواب ان نتركهم كما تفعل بهم روسيا الان
هذا من جهه لكن هناك ايضا فيما يتعلق
بمقتضيات الدفاع التقليديه هذه الايام
حدودنا خاليه لان روسيا نقلت قواتها الى
اوكرانيا وهذا يثبت ان الناتو ليس تهديدا
كانوا قد نشروا قوتهم على الحدود
شكرا جزيلا لك الينا فانتونين وزيره
خارجيه فنلندا شكرا لك
وبهذا ناتي او ربما نواصل في بقيه اخبارنا
اعلان وزاره الدفاع الادرى بجانيه تعليق
العمليات العسكريه واترك ربما هذا الخبر
لزميل نعم العمليه العسكريه في اقليمي
كارابا
بمجموعه ربما هذا الخبر سيقراه عبد القادر
ضمن ما تبقى من اخبار في لدى عبد القادر
عوده اليك عبد القادر شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
وعوده الى الدوحه
شكرا لك يا خديجه ولفريق الجزيره من
نيويورك اذا كما ذكرت خديجه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الادرى بجاليه تعليق العمليات
العسكريه في اقليم كارابا بمجموعه من
الشروط وقاد المتحدث باسم الوزاره انار
ايفازوف ان من بين تلك الشروط انسحاب
التشكيلات المسلحه الارمينيه من الاقليم
وتسليم اسلحتها الثقيله بالتنسيق مع قوه
حفظ السلام الروسيه
تبلغ وزاره الدفاع في جمهوريه اذربيجان
انها ستعلق الاجراءات المحليه لمكافحه
الارهاب وفقا للشروط التاليه تلقي تشكيلات
القوات المسلحه الارمينيه والجماعات
المسلحه الارمينيه غير الشرعيه الموجوده
في منطقه كراباخ بجمهوريه افربيجان
اسلحتها وتترك مواقعها القتاليه ومواقعها
العسكريه وينزع سلاحها بالكامل بالتوازي
تسلم جميع الاسلحه والمعدات الثقيله تنفذ
العمليات المذكوره بالتنسيق مع وحدات حفظ
السلام الروسيه
قال الرئيس الاذربيجانيه الهام علي ان
اذربيجان حققت كل اهدافها واستعاد سيادتها
خلال يوم واحد في العمليات في كارابا
واضاف في خطاب ان بلاده اتخذت على الفور
الخطوات اللازمه وعاقبت العدو على النحو
الصحيح وتم الانتهاء من جميع المهام في
يوم واحد فقط وتوعد عليه من سماهم
بالارهابيين بالعقاب مؤكدا ان اي استفزاز
من جهتهم سيقابل برد لائق بحسب تعبيره
عند الساعه الواحده من مساء اليوم اعلن عن
وقف اطلاق النار وقد التزم الطرف الاخر
بوقف اطلاق النار بشكل كامل وطبعا جاء ذلك
عقب الهجوم الذي اشتهدف اراضينا وبعد
الاعلان عن وقف اطلاق النار تم قبول
شروطنا كما وردت في الاتفاق ووفقا
لمبادئنا كما اعلنت للتو لقد حققت
اذربيجان كل اهدافها واستعادت سيادتها
خلال يوم واحد في العمليات في كاراباخ
ومن جهتها اعلنت تسلطات ارمنا اقليم كرباخ
انها وافقت على مقترح بعثه السلام الروسيه
بوقف اطلاق النار في الاقليم وقالت في
بيان انه نظرا للوضع الحالي ولان تحركات
المجتمع الدولي في اتجاه انهاء الحرب
وايجاد حل غير كافيه فان السلطات ارمن
كاراباخ تقبل باقتراح قياده قوات حفظ
السلام الروسيه بشان وقف اطلاق النار
واضاف البيان انه تم التوصل الى اتفاق لحل
التشكيلات العسكريه الارمنيه في كارباخ
وانسحاب الوحدات والعسكريين والمعدات
الثقيله الى ارمينيا
من جيته قال الكريملين ان اقليم كاراباخ
شان داخلي اذربيجاني وان اربيل اعترفت
بسياده باكو عليه واضاف ان روسيا تعول على
التزام اذربيجان بوعودها بعدم استهداف
المدنيين وانه لا اساس للحديث عن تصفيات
عرقيه في اقليم كارباخ في غضون ذلك قال
الرئيس الروسي فلادي لوسائل اعلام روسيه
ان بلاده على اتصال باطراف الصراع في
اقليم كاراباخ وقال بوتين خلال اجتماعه
بوزير الخارجيه الصيني ان موسكو تتوقع
تحقيق تسويه سلميه للوضع في كارباخ وان
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه تبذل قصار جهدها
لحمايه المدنيين
لعله الاستثناء
جوله القتال الاحدث في كاراباخ لم تدم
طويله
اذربيجان التي تعمل على اخضاع الجيب
الانفصالي في الاقليم علقت عملياتها
العسكريه لكن
تبلغ وزاره الدفاع في جمهوريه اذربيجان
انها ستعلق الاجراءات المحليه لمكافحه
الارهاب وفقا للشروط التاليه تلقي تشكيلات
القوات المسلحه الارمينيه والجماعات
المسلحه الارمينيه غير الشرعيه الموجوده
في منطقه كراباخ بجمهوريه اذربيجان
اسلحتها وتترك مواقعها القتاليه ومواقعها
العسكريه وينزع سلاحها بالكامل بالتوازي
تسلم جميع الاسلحه والمعدات الثقيله تنفذ
العمليات المذكوره بالتنسيق مع وحدات حفظ
السلام الروسيه
ارمينيا تراقب الموقف كدابها من كثب ومع
ذلك يبدو انها لم تكن طرفا في الاتفاق
الذي رعاه الروس
علمنا من الصفحات الرسميه لكرباخ انه
بواسطه روسيه قبلت سلطات الاقليم مقترحا
لبعثه حفظ السلام الروسيه بشان وقف اطلاق
النار اطلعنا على نص الاتفاق باعتبار ان
ارمينيا لم تشارك باي شكل من الاشكال في
صيغه هذا النص ولم تكن طرفا في المفاوضات
فقد اثار انتباهنا ان هذا النص يشير الى
اخراج القوات المسلحه الارمينيه المتبقيه
في الاقليم بالنسبه لنا هذا غير مفهوم
صرحنا في اكثر من مناسبه انه لا وجود
عسكريا ارمينيا هناك منذ اغسطس من عام
تطالب ارمينيا بضمانات امنيه دوليه لارمن
كارباخ لا يجعلها ذلك في من ان من
الانتقاد الشعبي لادارتها ملف النزاع في
الاقليم
عار عليكم يصرخ هذا الرجل مخاطبا حكومه
باشنيان يشعر هؤلاء المحتاجون في ريفاند
بان السلطات بلدهم خذلت ابناء قوميتهم في
ارض سخ وهي الاسم الارميني
هناك توالت الابتكاسات الميدانيه على
الوحدات العسكريه الارمنيه امام جيش
اذربيجان والان حملت على وقف القتال وحل
نفسها وتسليم ما تملكه من معدات وسلاح
معنا من باكو احمد شهيدوف الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن يوريفان ذكران رئيس تحرير
القسم العربي بوكاله الانباء الارمنيه
اهلا بكم ابدى بضيف
ما الذي حققته
باكو بالذي حدث هذا اليوم في كارباخ ووصفه
الرئيس علي بانه انتصار
نعم
قبل يومين الجيش الاذربيجاني
شلنا عمليات عسكريه في مكافحه الارهاب ضد
مجموعات ارمنيه موجوده في قاره وبعد 24
ساعه بعمليات عسكريه
ناجحه كل الارهابيين الارمن غير
القانونيين الحقت بهم الهزيمه واخيرا
الارهابيون الارنب في قرابه استسلموا
ويوم غد في مدينه يلبخ في اذربيجان سيكون
هناك
اجتماع سنعقد بين حكومه اذربيجان وبين
ممثلين السكان الارمن في قربا لا يوجد اي
اتفاق هذه ليست اتفاقيه سلام هذا مجرد
لقاء لحكومه مع مواطنيها وسكانها
الارمن الساكنين في
قرباهم مواطنون اذربيجانيون والحكومه
الاذربيجانيه ستتعامل معهم مباشره هم
ليسوا ارهابيين هم يعيشون هناك ونحن لم
نعقد ايه حوارات مع الارهابيين
فقط نريد
عيشا مشتركا وسلاما مع الساكنين الارمن في
قرابه وهذه مساله داخليه يا غربي لفهم
اعمق لما جرى هذا اليوم دعني اسال ضيفي من
يريفان السيد كابويان اصوات في اليابان
تحمل المسؤوليه لقوات حفظ السلام الروسيه
او لموسكو تحديدا لماذا
نعم مساء الخير
وللمشاهدين شكرا للاستضافه
باعتبار ان اتفاقيه تسعه نوفمبر بين روسيا
الراعي الاساسيه للاتفاقيه للروسيه
والطرف الثاني وارمينيا
بموجب هذه الاتفاقيه القوات حفل السلام
الروسيه تضمن امن وسلامه المواطنين في
جمهوريه المعلنه من طرف واحد ارصاف
جمهوريه ولكن للاسف هذا لم يحصل واذربيجان
استمرت في حصارها
[موسيقى]
منهجه وعنيفه وبربريه
بقصفها العشوائي
لعاصمه
ولذلك للاسف
الوسط الروسيه فشلت
القوات حافظ السلام الروس
تبادر او
تتفاعل بشكل
لتقوم بواجبها كما تقول سيد كابوي هنا
اتكلم عن القوات الروسيه
التفسير الاول لو السطحي والمباشر هو ان
المصالح
[موسيقى]
الازهريه
والروسيه في ابها في وجوهها وهي وصلت
لمرحله التنسيق التامه للاسف للاسف للجانب
الارمله للجانب الازرق هذا هذا اظن انه من
الايجابيات او من الاشياء التي حققتها في
هذه
لا يدعي علم اي اي صفقات غاز او غير صفقات
حاصله هنالك ولكن للاسف شعب الاصلي في في
بلادي وديفك الكريم من باكو يناقض نفسه
ويقول ارهابيين وبعد ذلك
كيف لهم ان يكونوا ارهابيين
في باكو تدعو المجتمع الدولي الى حمايه
المدنيين في اقليم كندا هل هناك ما يضمن
سلامه المدنيين خاصه في ظل انه اثناء هذه
الاشتباكات تم اجلاء المئات من سكان هذا
الاقليم من قبل قوه حفظ السلام الروسيه
اما عن الضمانات الضمان الاساسي
لامن واماني السكان الارمن هو دستور
جمهوريه اذربيجان وبعد الحوار كل السكان
الارمنيين في قرابه ستكون لهم نفس الحقوق
والواجبات والحريات حالهم حال مواطنين
اذربيجان الاخرى لن يتمتعوا باي وضع خاص
ابدا هم مواطنون
الارمن السكان في قاره
سيتمتعون بحريتهم لكن ستكون عليهم واجبات
ايضا ومسؤوليات عليهم ان يحترموا دوله
اذربيجان علم اذربي
الموقف في ريفال وفهم ردت فعلها اسال ضيفي
من ذكرى كابوي موسكو ردت وقالت ان يرضان
تعترف بان هذا الاقليم هو جزء طبعا بحكم
الاتفاقيات الماضيه التي تمت وكاله ريفان
جزء من هذا الاتفاق او الاعتراف بهذا
الاتفاق وبالتالي ما وجه الاحتجاج الان
سيد كابويان
الاحتجاج من اي طرف من قبل يريبان على ما
واجهتهم الاتهامات لموسكو
لم توجه اهتمامات اتهامات رسميه فقط تحليل
سياسي نعم
وفي ارمينيا
دوله ديمقراطيه ليست دوله ديكتاتوريه ولا
الاراء هناك المعارضه تنادي
بالاندماج التامه روسيا او جزء او تكون
حتى ارمينيا
هناك عدد
بدائل
توجهات السياسه الخارجيه الالمانيه وهذا
الطبيعي بطبيعه الشام ولكن
المساله مساله
هي معقده وكيفما ارادت اذربيجان ان تنفي
ان هناك شيء اسمه
هذا موجود الصراع كان مقتدم وكان له وعدت
اشكال ولكن
شكرا لك واعتذر منك ادركنا الوقت من
يريفان ذكران رئيس تحريره القسم العربي
بوكاله الانباء الارمينيه وكذلك الشكر
لضيفي من باكو احمد شهيدوف الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي
ختمت في ارمينيا التدريبات العسكريه
الامريكيه الارمنيه المشتركه ووجهت موسكو
انتقادات شديده لريفان عقب بدء التدريبات
لتتسع الخلافات بين البلدين ابرزها
انتقادات ارمينيه لروسيا بشان اقليم
كاراباخ مراسله الجزيره محمود الزئبق
الضوء من ارمينيا على بعض محطات التوتر
بين غريفان وموسكو
على غير العاده يرتفع العلم الامريكي في
ارمينيا ضمن تدريبات ايجل بارتنر العسكريه
المشتركه بين البلدين لتدريب قوات حفظ
السلام الارمينيه في اطار برنامج شراكه
النيتو من اجل السلام
لم تخفي موسكو امتعاظها من المشهد ووصف
وزير خارجيتها ما حدث بانه محاوله دوله
معاديه اختراق القوقاز
ازدادت حده الخلاف برفض ارمينيا اجراء
تدريبات عسكريه مماثله مع حليفها
الاستراتيجي روسيا في اطار منظمه معاهده
امن الجماعي التي تجمع الحليفين منذ ثلاثه
عقود وتمت تفاصيل اخرى تعكر صفوا قديما
للعلاقات بين البلدين
ابرزها معبر لاتشين الذي يصل بين ارمينيا
والارمني في اقليم كاراباخ خلال حرب عام
2020 سيطرت اذربيجان على جزء كبير من
كاراباخ وانقطع الاتصال الجغرافي للاقليمي
مع ارمينيا قطت معاهده السلام التي انهت
الحرب ان يكون المعبر تحت سيطره قوات حفظ
سلام روسيه لضمان حركته لكن يا ريفان تقول
ان المعبر اغلق منذ ديسمبر الماضي وان
شاحنات الاغذيه تمنع من عبوره اغلق
معبرلاتشين بعد قائمه طويله من الخلافات
بين ارمينيا واذربيجان بشان تفسير اتفاقيه
السلام لكن الحكومه الارمينيه تلوم روسيا
ايضا على اغلاق المعبر بحسب رئيسها فان
موسكو مثقله بعبئ حربها في اوكرانيا وهي
لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا للوفاء بدورها
كضامن لحركه المعبر او انها لا تريد ان
تفعل شيئا شافت العلاقات بين روسيا
وارمينيا خلافات اخرى في الاونه الاخيره
ظهرت كملاسنه بين المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ورئيس البرلمان الارميني كذلك في
تصديق البرلمان على نظام روما الاساسي
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
طلبت روسيا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه توضيحات
كثيره من يريفان واستدعت سفيرها في موسكو
لذلك الامر
بينما تحقق يا ريفان في شائعات عن وصول
عناصر فاجنر لارمينيا للمشاركه في انقلاب
على الحكومه وهي حكومه تظهر توجها اكبر
نحو الغرب يراسها صحفي سابق وصل الى
السلطه بعد ثوره شعبيه اطاحت برئيس مقرب
جدا من موسكو تكرر يا ريفان ان العلاقات
مع روسيا وثيقه وان اعترضتها بعض الخلافات
ويبقى لقادم الايام ان تخت تفاصيل اكثر
وضوحا لتلك العلاقات
ختام هذا الحصاد الى اللقاء باذن الله
يعطيك الصحه
[موسيقى]